♪
Birds make non-iridescent
structural colors
with combinations of
proteins and air
within particular cells
of their feather barbs.
♪
(Vinod)
I was studying how birds like
Blue Jays and Scrub Jays
and Kingfishers,
they make these kind of
blue colors
that doesn't shimmer,
that is not metallic.
We call it
non-iridescent.
(Richard)
In previous work,
we discovered that these
materials are self-assembled.
They come in two "flavors"
or shapes if you will,
one is spherical like
the bubbles in beer,
and the other is
kind of twisted
like the swirls in a bowl
of miso soup.
When Vinod was a
graduate student in my lab,
we wanted to characterize
all the
non-iridescent structurally
colored birds of the world
by whether or not they were
spherical or channel-like
in their nanostructure.
(Vinod)
One of the important
aspects of my research is using
collections-based specimens.
(Richard)
That meant putting
a lot of feathers in
the x-ray beam,
looking at how they
scatter the x-rays,
and reconstructing aspects of
their nanostructure
from those scattered particles.
(Vinod)
I was going through the drawers
of the Peabody Museum,
drawer by drawer,
and I came across these
really interesting birds
called Leafbirds.
They are normally found in South
and Southeast Asia.
(Richard)
Unlike all of
the bubbles in beer type,
the spherical,
or the miso soup,
the channel-types,
that we identified before,
we had something new,
we had a crystalline structure.
A structure with multiple peaks
in different and
unexpected places.
The experiments are
so well controlled,
the apparatus is so
beautifully structured,
that when you get these results,
you know it's not an error.
You know that immediately,
you've got something new.
What's interesting in
other research
we've looked at
these in butterflies.
So it turns out these particular
peaks come in certain ratios
and so we were
well prepared
to explore: "wait a minute, what
kind of crystals are these?"
and to identify this material
as a gyroid.
(Richard)
A gyroid is a shape,
that has a lot of
special properties.
At every point on
the surface of a gyroid,
it has the shape of a saddle
and that's occuring on every
point on the surface of a gyroid
(Vinod)
Coming to the actual structure
that we discovered,
it's called a single gyroid.
Single gyroids normally do
not naturally occur.
The birds, they're making
the single gyroid directly
and that offers a new way
completely new to physics.
(Richard)
I am really into this
because I care about birds.
But what's fascinating is that
this discovery
has huge implications
for technology
and for the practical world.
(Vinod)
The single gyroid
has superior electronic and
optical properties.
So that means that this
structure,
if you can make it large enough,
they can interact with sunlight
to trap the light.
(Richard)
Kind of a century after
the electronic revolution,
we're poised for another
technological revolution
in photonics.
So what that requires is
controlling the flow of light.
These optical structures that
birds are using to make colors,
are also the kinds of structures
you could use
to manipulate the flow of light
that allow you the development
of photonic technology.
The birds provide
an answer to that
because they create
the conditions
under which these materials
make themselves.
So that implies
a very practical line
for technologists to pursue:
Self-assembling,
photonic scale,
single network gyroids
in a lab.
Because the birds can do it,
we know,
we must be able to as well.
♪
♪♪